[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on everybody
welcome back to the saturday streams
we're doing it we are locking in our
infinite journeys submission today
lots of work we all spent about a month
on this thing
crunching and cranking um
today's my day to animate my art
and i'm a little behind you know but
that's how it goes
and uh
yeah it's gonna be a lot of key frames
today i got some motion capture recorded
i did it yesterday recorded some mocap
with my good friend brett
um
so i'm basically going to take that data
go into rococo
do a little cleanup i'm going to do some
cleanup later after the stream
because i want it to be as perfect as
possible but i'm essentially going to
bring this in to my scene in cinema 4d
and start animating all the switches all
the knobs all the dials
um all that good stuff and then i have
an after effects project file where i'm
going to animate all the like rpms and
all the different huds and readouts and
whatnot that you're going to see on the
actual cockpit spaceship so
let's just jump into it i mean we got a
lot of work to do
thank you all for coming by i appreciate
you all very very much um
we got a super chat already
who's this who is sid yo i appreciate
you thank you very much for that super
chat that's awesome of you
um really appreciate the support there
super super cool
uh no this is not the judging stream the
judging stream is next weekend that is
saturday the fifth i believe we're doing
uh some judging some live judging i'm
still locking the judges we got one
locked in so far but i'ma hold that for
now i'm gonna hold that info
right now um
but i will say he's a super cool dude
and i'm very excited trying to get a
second right now trying to lock in a
second but
um
you know we'll see we'll get there
only in a matter of time y'all so you
all have like what like just under two
days
left to get this stuff in
it's gonna be uh
tomorrow february 27th at 11 59 pm pst
or 2359
if you all are on that military time or
i don't know i don't know what other
what other countries use the 12 hour
clock but i prefer the 24 hour clock
myself
all right
so
i've decided to save all the detail
texturing for last because
i want to be able to view my scene in
as real time as possible in c4d textures
are just going to slow me down so to
animate i'm going to have to
essentially save the texturing for later
now the first step here like i mentioned
i recorded some mocap
in uh rococo
so let me just play this for y'all
basically i'm sitting down
in the chair
flip my visor down
grab the steering wheel do a couple
things
start the engine boom engines going
flip a couple switches up here flip some
other switches down there crank the
throttle that's what my right hand is
doing left hand on steering wheel right
hand on the shifter bam shift and take
off
and we shift again
boom
and keep going keep going keep going
and probably here bam is where i'm a cut
out of the scene
so
let me just export this right now into
c4d
so we can actually have
a sense of when
all the knobs and dials need to be
animated i also want to
animate some like
you know dangly little like straps
potentially or at least like a like
maybe a necklace hanging from the rear
view mirror
where the rear view mirror would be
you know that kind of stuff
um but i might do that we'll see how
much time we got you know
i definitely want to get into after
effects and animate
the hud
for like the miles per hour the gear
shifter all that kind of stuff so i'd
probably hop into that first but let's
go ahead and export this
let's see yeah that's right it's not
five seconds
my render is starting
the
entire montage so
i chose to do something that
uh
more fits the emotion and gets people
buttered up and ready for all of the
submissions that you're gonna see so i'm
like cranking up the
the engine starting the engine revving
it up and setting the tone for the
montage and then i
it starts stationary and then it blasts
off and then the montage will start so
yep
we are doing it adam shout outs thank
you for that super chat just submitted
your render you weren't able to clean it
up as much as you wanted because you got
exams still super proud of it love the
streams adam thank you so much i
appreciate you
um
that's awesome man way to deliver way to
deliver there's a lot of people who are
taking it down to that last minute
and i know it's going to be stressful
down to that last minute um but i'm glad
you got yours in you don't have to worry
about it anymore congratulations
um and to everyone who has submitted so
far thank you thank you so much for
putting all that hard work and i know
there's a lot of you out there who are
still working on your stuff all right so
keep it up
don't push it too close all right you
don't want to go past
the the
the deadline there because then it
wouldn't be in
the top 100 montage even if it's
top 100 worthy i i just couldn't do it
um
and it pains me so please get it in on
time people please
all right let's export this thing so i'm
gonna right click this let's export
okay
we want
data included we don't need face data
i don't think we need trackers the body
mesh i want to include
fbx
fps
24
and that should be
good to go
all right so
[Music]
let's see i'll just desktop it for now
and put it in the right place
all right jack k is going to get
the render in today very good stuff i'm
excited for that
what is the submission time in europe
well it's pacific standard time
um basing off the submission uh time for
pacific standard time so you're just
gonna have to do the math there or go to
google type it in
you know europe time to uh pst
as most people will have to do you know
alrighty
let's go ahead and open up
that mocap
first let's get it in the right folder
because we got to be organized
unlike me look at this
there's a mess here
i gotta clean that stuff up
all right but yeah let's get this take
five in in the right spot here
let's just see
what it looks like
beautiful
beautiful
this is exactly
exactly what we need here
awesome so i'm just going to trim this
up here let's see
probably start it like here
shift
f3
to bring up
your keyframes here
and i want to save that keyframe the uh
the t pose keyframe on frame
zero
so
let's actually leave it there
and we'll call it there boom
yo what's up visual
visual in the house one of the
moderators
the og moderators good stuff
we got ronin in the house as well what's
up ronin
good to see you here
another one of the classic moderators i
mean i guess every moderator's classic
at this point because we hadn't changed
moderators
we only added a handful probably i don't
know maybe less than a year in
um
but it's good to have all y'all in here
always
we're working on some cool stuff we got
some really cool stuff a pretty cool
announcement
for the discord server coming out next
week
we got a nice announcement for you all
during the live judging stream
so
don't miss that one don't miss that
stream next week it's gonna be a good
one
all right so it looks like we got
yeah somewhere in here we probably have
thousand frames or so boom okay 10.29
right so let's copy this and bring it
into
our scene
and we'll hide
our character
all right something like that
now i'm gonna have to move that steering
wheel in a little bit closer
that's already
already chugging my scene here so i
probably have to hide some stuff
and there we go sweet we got our first
crash
good times
come on now if you're gonna crash just
crash on me
let's draw uh lopstars congrats on
getting your rendering good stuff
vishwas you are very welcome thanks for
hopping in here
all right come on now
now one crash a day is all we need i
agree
i agree
belly good question will it be judged
like alternate realities or dynamic
machines it'll definitely be judged like
dynamic machines i'm not trying to put
any top 100 artist
down for making top 100 um we're gonna
react to the awesome top 100 pieces of
art and then we're going to announce the
top five winners at the end of that
of that uh once we get through all those
reactions and we show every cool piece
of art jim rice yo thank you for the
super chat you modeled your own
character for this challenge with the
help of 3d scans of your own face don't
judge the hands when you see it hey i
understand i tried to do a photo scan
yesterday it did not work out
i think i'm going to have to at this
point i'm gonna have to buy a character
because
the photo scan it's maybe you would work
for a mid-ground shot detail-wise but
for a close-up is definitely not gonna
work
um i think character work is probably my
biggest
struggle you know
during this challenge actually there's a
lot of struggles during this challenge
for me trying to balance
the art that i'm doing trying to balance
the um
you know the ambition and the idea i
want to do while also trying to balance
putting on the the challenge itself
so i'm definitely learning a lot of
lessons on this one
i didn't even complete my dynamic
machines submission
um
which sucks because i put i put a lot of
work into it but
it was just mismanagement of schedule
and timing and like i'm learning that
lesson and right here i might i'm like
i don't know probably
75 percent done
70 percent done with my submission right
now
and
as long as i get it done by the
let's see by the
by the top 100 montage then i'll be good
but honestly like it's gonna take this
will be full time judging all of this
stuff and getting the top 100 montage
live so
yeah i if i don't get my art done in the
next couple days here i'm going to be
i'm going to be in trouble so
i'm feeling it it's crunchy
it is crunchy no doubt
all right for some reason
this is still
freezing on me
wow okay
that's not good
let's try that again
it is what it is baby i'm not too
worried
caleb yes you had a ton of problems but
you learned a ton
love how it turned out in the end
and submitted last night congratulations
you're in the clear you've done it
you've submitted
good stuff very very good stuff
all right let's um
let's do this right okay
if you shift drag
anything into your scene it's gonna
merge it
uh
as opposed to opening up a new project
so that's one i use all the time
i think it was just under 1200 frames
shift f3 will bring up
the dope sheet
aka your key frames i'm just going to
move this over to the next screen
i want to save that first uh
that first frame because that's that
t-pose
probably start it right in here
frame 70.
all right
yeah animating characters and whatnot is
definitely
my weak point
i feel like i got so many weak points
um
modeling
that's a pretty that's a weak point for
me for sure
i love texturing but i feel like i do it
the hard way
this challenge really taught me that i
need to update my workflow
and that's what i learned from this one
i need to get smart about this stuff if
i'm going to continue doing this kind of
work you know
i love
environments and whatnot that's that's
my favorite
certainly
now i'm getting some weird stuff here um
my key frames are looking all off i
think it's because
my frame rate is wrong let's
uh i know i yeah okay okay it's because
i merged i merged the scene i brought a
24 frames per second
animation into a 30 fps composition so
like wow okay geez
that's nuts
it's one of those days huh
567 people up in here
watching me crash and burn but hey you
know what
it's okay
good let's do this
oh we're gonna problem solve this all
right we're in it you know
jones left says
please do an environment only focus
challenge none of this foreground
nonsense dude i'm kind of feeling it
with you right now
wow it's still like frozen
what is going on
all right let's close this
brutal y'all
bring it on though like let's go
let's go
all right
an environment only challenge
interesting okay okay i'm 100 down for
that
you have to figure out though what's the
subject you always need a subject of
some sort you know um
what would the thing be how would it how
would the environment only challenge
work is it like a
hmm
it could oh interesting well now it gets
now it gets advanced but like
it's the same environment
and you see what it looks like over time
from all different time periods and like
the different settlements that have been
built there
winter
you know you got some snowy scene
summer spring fall all that stuff
could be interesting
okay
let's try this again
okay i'm saving this junk right now
all right
24 fps scene
shift
f3 for the dope sheet
just right clicking that little
hamburger right there that three stack
and uh
i'm going to pull up my keyframes
i think we started on frame 70
so i'm gonna delete all of these guys
hopefully this will be the last time we
do this
but i'm not making any promises y'all i
want that t-pose
i'm gonna bring that right up in there
and
let's take all of this and scoot it on
over
[Music]
oh goodness come on now
when things get laggy that's when it
gets scary it's like
the submissions coming up
you got your deadline
trying to finish your art
but then everything's just slowing down
and getting crunchy
it's not a good place to be it doesn't
doesn't feel good that's for sure
nevertheless
we persevere okay
all right i'm gonna call it right there
boom
and then i'm just scoot this all in to
frame zero
i don't think it's the polygons
on the model i think it's just the fact
that i'm dealing with like
1300 key frames at once and i'm trying
to move 1300
things times all of the i mean look 1300
keyframes
it's really more than that
this is what i'm trying to work with
right here you know what i'm saying
like
there's a lot of data
woo
that's a lot of data
okay let's try that again
i wish i just don't know enough like is
there a way to just be like frame zero
snap it to frame zero
like in after effects and you just
get it up on frame zero
with the tilde key
to bring it to the playhead that's a
that's a nice one
but
okay
save save save save
all right cool cool
i mean honestly we could do it this way
i am gonna do it this way this is gonna
be the cheat way
but
it's the way i'm gonna do it
because
i'll explain this in a minute but let me
just
one step at a time here
yeah doing the vehicle on the the
environment could work
that could certainly work
or you can switch out the vehicle if you
want
or maybe it's the same vehicle
everyone gets the same vehicle but you
can color it however you want
all right
uh
so basically what i'm gonna do
is
animate all these switches and levers
and
everything
minus the character i'm going to be
using this as a timing reference
all right so i know that this lever boom
needs to happen
here
268.
we'll animate this up at 260
the reason i'm doing it like this is
because i'm actually going to
like if i actually had my character in
here
do this for a couple reasons my brain
thinks
too quick and i start saying stuff that
doesn't make sense um
okay so basically the reason i'm
animating this stuff with my character
in another scene one is for
um
frame rate so i can work smoothly and
it's not super crunchy i hate working
with a crunchy
a crunchy scene
um
second is because it's not even the real
character
so if i had the real character with the
actual like
dimensions of the body and the thickness
of their hand and everything
then maybe but i don't have that right
now and that's something i'm gonna have
to do
after this stream
essentially
um because my photo scan that i tried
yesterday didn't work so i'm gonna have
to figure that out it's just i'm trying
to do as much as i can right now
um
but
all the mocap data essentially needs to
be cleaned up i need to clean it up as
much as possible so it works for the
foreground there can't be any
jitteriness or clipping or anything like
that so it's gonna be a lot of work to
go in and like
clean that stuff up
and i can all and essentially what i'll
do is when we do that
um i think i'm going to work with a
friend here in maya to do that and
i'm going to export out this scene as an
fbx
and just time it all up then as well so
for now
i'm just gonna go through and hit all
these switches
and get those keyframes in place
so it's time to animate
well also just want to say i got the
background going
back here
got some mountains
and i also have
some
let's see
fake this like fake fog cards
which are essentially just uh
i have
these uh whatchamacallit
a couple materials on here
that are gradients
where they're
opaque at the bottom and transparent on
top
different colors and whatnot and it
fakes the fog
otherwise it would take me
12 years to render this thing
and what it's looking like
is something like this let me pull it up
for you
something like that
so we have the fake fog in the
background
it's looking really nice it's just an
hdri uh it's a grayscale gorilla hdri
for the sky
and
this is just a different
different sky essentially with some
lit monitors here
and yeah those fog cards you can't even
tell that they're there but it looks
natural
it definitely looks natural i can maybe
tweak it a little bit but
i'm feeling pretty good about that and
saving me so much
vram so much
time
and it's something i'll go into uh in
detail when i break down
this piece of art
later in i think april
is when that's coming out
okay
back to animation
styles morales
thank you for that super chat
appreciate you brother good stuff
shout outs to you
all right random renders asks how did i
know where to move my hand to when doing
the mocap doesn't it need to be pretty
accurate also did you have a physical
reference for the stuff you interact
with great question that brings up a
great point i'ma pull it up for you
yesterday i spent i spent all day
yesterday
uh with my good friend brett driver
and we set up
we set up this uh this little scene here
i'm just sitting down
chilling
in the office with all of this crap
set up and it's basically
all of these little pieces here all
these like stools and
random looking pieces of stuff
it's in a very specific place and the
way
we set that up
i think there's
a take here where he shows it yep right
here so you can see
i'm doing live link here in rococo to
c4d
and i'm
generally lining up
where the real things are
to where the actual like switches and
levers are
right
and that'll be tweaked later i'll tweak
that later in maya and clean it up just
because it'd be a lot faster to do in
maya
um
see so i think you guys get the idea of
how that's going down
but basically
this is one of the takes here
where we've kind of lined everything up
and the key here is to just actually be
holding on to real things see like i'm
holding onto the steering wheel with my
left hand i'm holding on to this lever
up here and i'll be able to animate the
arm later
and i'm pressing real things i have the
box
i got my tripod here that's the gear
shifter i think i messed that take up
but
y'all get the idea
i'm just making sure everything's lined
up it doesn't have to be exact
because there is a little bit of drift
and whatnot um
i'm surrounded by a bunch of metal stuff
it's a magnet kind of a system so
you know you try and get as accurate as
you possibly can
and let me see if i can show you any
other
[Music]
yeah
yeah so like
basically my hand is touching all these
buttons here
and we just take it piece by piece
so that's how i did the the mocap for
this
all right
back to it
all right so it looks like we have
so f and g
is uh skipping frames forward and back
so
boom starts to come up there at
268
to 271.
all right
cool all right so this piece gets
animated up how do i want to do this
the top piece
i originally had to be a press
but i thought it'd be cool to like pull
it up like this or something
maybe we start it down like this
and then it pulls up to
here so make a keyframe
and another keyframe something like that
very very simple
pulls that up
and
we're gonna pop this i believe this is
the next thing i do is i pop this open
yeah it's a thumb flick and a finger
flick so the thumb
boom
pops that open
at frame what
288 and the fingers come in
298
okay
288 298
sweet all right it's all separated great
so i want to change that anchor point
hitting l
and
we'll get that about centered there
boom 288
and it's a flick on and i'd probably be
some like a spring-loaded thing
opens up keyframe
come forward two frames
come forward four frames make a keyframe
go back two frames and like just bring
it down just a little bit like that
that way it looks like it kind of
springs back on itself
and it's hard to tell with my frame rate
so low
i guess that's it
let me see if i can clear some stuff out
of this scene so we can get a good frame
rate back
um we can do the entire environment
the landscape can go
and we can probably turn off
all of the subdivision surfaces
so i'm gonna just type in
subdivision surface
you can see how we have a lot of them
i wonder if we just turn those turn
those off
if we'll be good to go and what is this
one doing
i see i see
yeah so literally every subdivision
surface
i'm a disabled
and then we should be able to get a
better frame rate
interesting
anyway i'll check that a second we got a
super chat what's up brian
good stuff man thanks for the support i
appreciate you very much
clint great job as always sent my first
challenge and i'm super excited yes
trying to put my video on the discord
showcase channel but i can't write on it
yeah so since we
since we started the patreon basically
only a certain part of the server is
free the other part is part of the
patreon five dollar community tier
um
[Music]
and then we also close down the the work
in progress channel just so that people
don't post any weird stuff on stream um
but i will be going through your guys's
submissions
probably in the middle of the stream or
so
um but yeah brian we're working on it
you know like we're trying to find that
balance of like what's worth it for that
five dollar patreon tier and what should
be free to literally everyone i know
that one thing that
you know attaching it to the patreon
does help with is like
sometimes you have people come in and
start scamming and spamming and doing
you know
not malicious stuff but like
you know you just it's open to literally
everyone now so
it makes it a lot more difficult to keep
it um
i don't know just to keep it clean so
we're trying to find that balance but
regardless man i appreciate that super
chat thank you very much
um
and save the polar bears yo
welcome back thank you again you won't
be able to finish you're ready for this
challenge but definitely learned enough
to do all the weekly and future monthly
challenges hey
that's what's up that's a great mindset
to have i really appreciate that mindset
i think it's awesome
and yeah absolutely man it's all about
learning and growing so if you're doing
that then you're winning where all of us
are winning if we're doing that so
heck yeah
hamburger god shout outs man that's
what's up
all right um
yeah someone said here turn off my
viewport effects that's a great idea how
about i do that shift v let's go to hud
let's turn off
um
effects
just turn off the effects
sounds like a great idea
my frame rate is still not as good as it
can be which is very strange
so like 16
or something
anyway
i'm going to roll with it
roll with the punches um is there
anything else we can do
maybe we can get rid of uh
all of um let's get rid of the floor
real quick
she's not gonna do much but
and let's also hide
hmm
okay let's see if i can do this
basically everything except for
let me just solo
some stuff here
switchboard left and right
i solo that
hmm
all right what about this
it's the same fps i wonder why
that's very strange
how is that worse
well whatever
moving on
so i'm gonna go another two frames make
a keyframe
and have that bounce effect kind of
go one more just a little bit
right so it really
really gets in there boom
so look maybe a little much
what happens if we
scrunch all these keyframes together
let's do this right
yeah that's too fast
it's probably good where it was to be
honest
minus those last two
get this up one
and keep it snappy
just not have it come back as much
there it is
that looks good
that feels good
all right so we hit this boom
and then 10 frames later on 98 it goes
this guy gets flicked on
now the easy way of doing this oh and i
think i'm gonna go for it is just to go
a 180 flip on it
so
yeah let's do that let's cheat
we'll go
let's see 180.
hit that keyframe
and from the camera's perspective
it's gonna be so small
yep that looks like it turns all right
hold on
let's try it again
let's try one frame
that's
better
i think that works
i don't think people will be able to
tell
that's not good
shoot i really need to
detach all this
my goodness
i guess that would be ah i guess that
would be the way to do it
but they're everywhere
jamil artworks if i knew how to how to
use a plane and delay effector
i
would
do it but i don't know how to do it
i have many things to learn my friend
many things to learn
that's what i'm saying i feel like my
workflow is very inefficient
go forward that frame and move it up
just a bit
this feels so inefficient
i mean that's about as good as it's
going to get um
in the time
i want to do it in
control d change that view clipping to
small
there we go
i wonder if fixing one like or fixing
every single one like that is gonna take
more time than just fixing the one doing
it right
it just comes down to
the instances i need to update the
instance itself so
let's find it um
where is the original switch
on the left switchboard
that is the original switch right here
so whatever i do to this
these instances will be updated
if i scale it those will scale
but if i chop it the others won't be
chopped i don't think
i just don't have to update all these
darn switches
screw it
i'ma do it
the janky way anyway moving on
that's done
now it's the ignition
so
reach the hand on the ignition
and
turn
[Music]
on frame 3
fifty-six
of course
let's center it up maybe
uh it's even worse amazing um
ignition
let's go to
the axis center tool
reset it execute and hopefully now it's
centered no
why what
oh because it's got all this garbage
down there okay
well that's an easy fix
let's get that lasso selection
and get rid of that
let's center it up
really okay let's
try the axis center tool again
all right that's what we need now i
guess technically it is this top piece
doing a thing so
i am going to have to break this up
all right it's getting all that stuff
but we don't want all that stuff
okay let's try
point mode
lasso again
um
all right up to break it up
and that's what we'll be animating
i'll group this as ignition
i'll probably start it let's see let's
start it like
this
turns to the right
355 what
yeah 355.
very simple
very very simple
all right then from here
i do a bunch of stuff on the other side
so
i grab the lever up here
hang on to it i go
one
two
three
down the line one one two three down the
line okay
so let's hit these middle three
and i'm flicking them down
so
actually we can do all this at once
grab all three of these
r for rotate
per object transformation we'll check
that
and let's see what the timing is on this
440
447
or 57
or 40
447
or 57
okay
all right
and i don't think
you're even gonna
see that tiny little pop
from where we're at
yeah that's
can't even see it
perfect
perfect all right moving on
let's see what else we got all right so
i'm still hanging on to this lever up
here which is gonna i'm gonna throttle
that forward over
the period of time here but i'm gonna
deal with these other switches first
so i flick them one
two
let's see
all right there's some there's some
business going on here
let's see
that's two finger flick one
two
and i think i went
forward
yeah those ones are forward one two
one
one
all right
a lot of switches there all right let's
start with the first set
bam
481
a pair of them and then
490
481
and 490.
jimmy james i see you
give me two seconds here
481
and 490. this will be these guys down
here
481 and 490.
bam we'll grab these guys
per object rotation
checked
make a keyframe
for the frame
180 yep
and then
or 90
on these guys
bam
yep
and you know what let's let's go the
extra let's go the extra mile so
technically this back one
let's lag it behind
by one frame
just to give it a little extra
a little extra something
whatever that's worth
[Music]
sweet jimmy james
shout outs to you challenge is great
i'm locked in to finish by the wire
that's what's up that's good news
what is my plan when i drop the mocap in
if it doesn't align with the switches
how are you gonna adjust it
that is a great question so um
i'm gonna have to
essentially move the arms
move the wrist move the fingers
uh to hit
all of this stuff
and
doing it in c4d
is gonna take a lot longer
um this i literally learned this
yesterday um
and i still don't know the workflow i'm
gonna learn it though
um
a good friend is gonna help here so
basically
instead of doing this in c4d
we're gonna do it in maya
where things have like automatic ik and
everything
um
and we're gonna line it up that way
so i'm essentially going to bounce out a
like an fbx here
where
they'll be able to see we'll have a
character
and we'll have the mocap data and we'll
actually have the set and then we'll be
able to line it up based off of like the
mocap data that's why i'm sticking to
these individual
frame numbers here for all these
switches i'm trying to keep it as close
as possible so that
when bringing it into maya
and retarget stuff
it'll fit perfectly because right now
like
mocap is fantastic it certainly saved me
weeks probably here
but it's still not perfect and there
needs to be cleanup so
especially if it's in the foreground
especially if you don't want clipping
especially if you want it to be perfect
which i do
um
it has to be tweaked it has to be like
manually
keyframed to
hit the hit the points you're trying to
hit
so
it's gonna be a hoot it's gonna be a lot
but
it'll be worth it it'll be worth it i'm
just such a perfectionist you know like
it's tough
it's tough the other way to do it is to
just hand animate it which is certainly
possible
um and might be
maybe that's the faster way in this case
you know
um but i'm so unskilled at that i
maybe if that's all i had to do for the
month
then i would give it a go but like i'm
at the point here where i don't have any
more time
so
i'm sticking to what i know even if what
i know
might be the slower route
so
yeah lots of lessons to learn on this
one i i've learned a lot
and i think i figured out what i want to
learn throughout this year
what i want to get good at there are
some things that i'm okay not being good
at
like that'll be all right
but there are other things that's like
come on i should i should be better at
this so
yeah i'm learning like i said i'm
learning with you guys learning and
growing together it's the together part
you know but jimmy james i appreciate
that uh that super chat that's very kind
of you thank you so much
we got 611 people up in here
awesome very good stuff welcome
everybody thanks for hanging out with us
jimmy james amazing you're in the same
boat all right having weird results with
uh creating new motion clips on top of
the data seems like keyframes don't
compensate for it a tug of war
so jimmy james i have a tutorial on my
channel
let me see if i can
pull it up for you really quick um
but i go over this it was part of the
alternate reality stuff um
maybe i can watch my own tutorial and
learn a thing or two
let's see
um so if we go to videos and it is the
one
called it's called c4d quick tip
add any 3d character
to any
motion
capture data
let me just paste it in the chat for you
and i go over
how to add that motion on top as well
so maybe give that a watch and see and
see what's up and see if that helps you
who knows maybe it'll help me
um
all right moving on so we have some more
switches to hit here
so i move up to the next panel
that's a switch
it looks like i do
let's see
it's like a one two three four things
yeah it's
the one two three four for sure so it's
uh
double
index finger
double
index finger
okay
so that'll be
these guys
double index finger
double
index finger going up
the length of this thing okay
and i'm probably gonna bring all this
stuff down
just to get a little closer to the hand
not walking king
what's up
can't wait to see all the creations me
too
i am so excited that is the best part
is being able to see everything and
cutting these montages that is like my
absolute favorite part of this whole
thing
goodness gracious
really all right
all right that's everything
that's doing weird stuff
that's normal all right good
all right let's figure out this timing
505
512
505 and 512.
actually chad why don't you help me out
505
512
526
534 505 512
i forgot the other two
thanks soto 505 512
526 and 534
amazing
all righty
oh that's so funny that
they thought it was a phone number it's
message held for review
all right 505.
thanks melvin
me b-man
thank you
for the super chat very kind of you
i like that little animated gif too
that's nice
thank you so much that's awesome
512
interesting
yes there we go there we go 512.
oh this is a single this is a single i
remember
bam single all right double up here
526
thank you soto thank you melvin
we got a double situation here
and then a single at
five
34
and i'm gonna knock this one out of sync
let's see what it looks like
cool
we got some switches being switched my
goodness
vj verma in the house once again i see
you from time to time
and my goodness i appreciate these super
chats every single time you are
incredible
i really appreciate that support that's
super awesome of you
um and not even a message too that's the
thing not even a message just a straight
up support super chat thank you sir
thank you very much
amazing
y'all are awesome
thank you so much
um
let's see
let's see all right we got that side
done let's um
let's crank this little uh this lever
here
i think it's time to crank this lever
i've been waiting to crank this lever
ever since i modeled it
you could tell you could tell i had it
ready to go
okay
um
this is gonna be a gradual one
this is going to be the throttle this is
what's gonna hype up the whole montage
this lever is the hype lever right here
because
it's connected to the
engine and uh there's gonna be some nice
sound design
as this lever goes we're gonna be like
be one of those kind of levers you know
that's a good lever
so i'm gonna get that lever right now um
let's see
let's go back to 400.
so my hand is on this lever from let's
just see what this is
hands on the lever
i want to start cranking right
like click these and i want to start
cranking right here
probably
475
to 4 to 5
35 475
535 four seventy five
five thirty five boy i see them super
chats let me memorize these numbers four
thirty five
to five
goddamn
435
no i'm getting this wrong again
450 god let's make it simple 450
to
5 30.
4 50 to 5 30. all right all right all
right all right 450.
oh
450
to 530
and that's gonna be a hype
lever right there
all the way forward
like bam
right up in there sweet
and i'mma easy ease this thing i think
it defaults to easy
that's gonna be good that's gonna be
good y'all we got some super chats
popping off right now what is going on
y'all are crazy
um
let's see
sand
sanctivan
uh
what what is up what is up you wanted to
take part in this challenge but i had
projects i had to work on sad face
hope there will be another challenge
there will be another challenge don't
you worry sanctiven
it will be another challenge
the plan is uh later this year that's
all i'm gonna say
that is all we're gonna say at this time
but
i believe in you
counting on you and
don't be so sad it's okay
you know it'll be all right you got
other projects i hope you learned stuff
on those projects
me bee man
we got the little game controller thank
you very much i appreciate you thank you
for the super chat very very very kind
of you
very good stuff
that's amazing no message necessary just
good stuff
moises moses garcia you're loving how
this is turning out keep it up much love
much love to you moises moses
um
i'm loving it too man i wish i didn't
bite off so much
every single time i just bite off just
take these big bites you know massive
bites
i can't i can't keep my
just food
coming out of my mouth you know
i can't keep it down it's just ah
maybe that's how i'll do my breakdown is
i'll just do it with the mouth full of
food
who knows michael james thank you for
that super chat very kind of your
brother double
doubling up on them super chats thank
you thank you to all you all for the
super chats very very kind very
appreciated
um and very helpful
michael james
such an inspiration can't wait to see
the final product do you think you'll
finish in time heck no i'm not going to
finish some time look
i've made i've made some realizations
i've made decisions and i've made
realizations look no we're going back
okay look so basically
um
here first off here's my decision
uh i want to create a render that starts
the top 100 montage
so it's not five seconds it's there to
kind of butter up the audience to get
everyone in their seats you know get
your popcorn get your kombucha whatever
the heck
um i want to set the tone with some nice
sound design with some nice visuals with
a cool animation so i think mine is like
1200 frames it's not uh the 120 frames
it's much longer
um because i want to set the tone
right so that's one thing um
as long as i can get it done by the
montage i'm good right so i'm biting off
a whole lot here
hopefully not more than i can chew i'm
really trying to knock this out
so i am going beyond the deadline to get
this thing done
because i got a lot of things going on
at this blah blah blah right okay but
here's what i've learned i learned that
it's probably better if i just stick to
the deadline with y'all one it sets a
better example and two
it goes much much easier on myself
because just because the the
challenge deadline comes up
oh yeah technically i have time
to get my render in before the top 100
montage nah technically not because i
have to judge all that stuff and i have
to edit all the all the top 100 montages
and whatnot right or the one top 100
montage
so
it's a lot of work i can't just assume
that i'm gonna have time after
the deadline to get this done so i'm
learning this now
so i think next challenge we do together
um i'm gonna come in on time with y'all
and i'm probably going to do something a
bit more minimalistic so i can
accomplish it within
three weeks
yeah three weeks
so i need to cater my ideas
more toward the time i have as opposed
to just maxing out the the idea and
seeing what happens
scheduling is the biggest challenge for
me so
yeah i'm working on it y'all i'm working
on it
we got more super chats i'll stay here
while uh
while we got it so
who do we have we have brendan huskin i
appreciate you very much
yo clint uh those spec frames are slick
where you get them i appreciate you uh i
got them from zenny optical i love zenny
optical of course the stream is not
sponsored by zenioptical
um but
um they have super cheap frames
and so you can get a couple right you
have a couple pairs of different glasses
different looks they got shades you can
get prescription shades there it's just
really really cheap so that's where i go
for my glasses
and jeffrey larson with the super chat
shout outs to you you love pinball but i
missed making something for dynamic
machines keep rocking that hype throttle
dude i'm down for the hype throttle
seriously i just want to hype on my desk
that would be sick
um
all good man all good there'll be more
challenges later on
but uh but stick with it
i don't know i was gonna say something
right there but i don't have anything to
say all right moving on
moving on
hype throttle
all right um
the hyped arm was pretty quick
i started too
[Music]
soon i sound like a theremin now
all right i'ma stop doing that
all right um what's after hype throttle
we got another hype throttle but it's a
different kind of hype throttle so here
let's let's let's see we got hype
throttle
bam all right steering wheel hang on the
steering wheel
hand on the shifter
and we go into
boom shift into
probably 6
20
625 because the hand is off of it
at 6 35
and is off at 6 35 okay so
so let's get this throttle here bam this
one right down here
it's probably a snap back thing
i don't know how that works
uh but i'ma make it up we're making
things up all right that's how we do it
6 35 i said
all right 6 35 the hand is off
all right
so we'll make a keyframe there but i
also
probably shift it at
i don't know 6 29 or something i'll make
a keyframe at 629 but i also i wanted to
come back to that point so it's going to
snap back
let's say
6 37 it snaps back okay so
in that time boom we shift it up
and it's going to be something like
that shift needs to be quicker
no
something like that something like that
if it snaps back in one frame i think
that's too quick
but maybe that's i don't know maybe
that's what it is
it needs to be snappy
it's a one frame thing i could tweak it
later
but
i think that's good for now and
basically
and i'm gonna do an extra little thing
here it snaps back
and i'm gonna give it just a little
bounce back technically
it's probably kind of janky if you're
getting bounce back
but
i'ma just do it okay
that'd be super janky
but just a little bit you know just a
little bit of feedback
yeah that's it
very subtle
and again probably wouldn't happen
because it's made of metal
you know
dude sodamonte getting some love
in the chat i love it i love it
did you just i didn't even see your
comment out of bounce on the snapback i
didn't even see that
but we're synchronized here
yeah just a little something you know
just a little
a little something
okay
and then we're gonna basically duplicate
that snap
a couple times throughout this animation
right so
boom
hand is
off
at 763.
well we got 763
and 911
763 and 911
763
and 9 11.
wonderful all right
it's in place it's done
let's see what we're looking like
let's take a look at the whole thing
right
and i'm just gonna try it i'm just gonna
try it all right i'ma copy this guy in
paste it into the scene
now these hands are not going to line up
all right
but
see what we can do all right
something like that generally
all right let's see what happens
visor comes down
that comes up
boom
yeah
timing's right
awesome yeah i mean that's pretty much
pretty much it and then i'll have to
connect all of the stuff
in maya
sync up all these hands and
and whatnot i know i need to bring the
steering wheel forward
but that's it
all right
10 37.
bam
all right so from here
hmm
now i technically need to animate the
car going i need to animate some camera
shake and stuff
but i'd rather just hop in after effects
and animate some hud and stuff and
design a hud so let's do that that
sounds like fun
how long does it take to master 3d it
takes two years
uh
312 days
and
3 hours
42 minutes
and 8 seconds
aniket i'm just joking um
how long does it take to master 3d
man well how long is it to master
let's just say how long does it take to
master a specific thing how long would
it take to master
oh boy
drawing a circle how long would it take
mask to master drawing a circle let's
just say a sphere a sphere
a shaded sphere
i don't know
i don't know
but how long would it take to master
drawing
well depends on what you're trying to
draw
seriously you know it could be
who knows who knows really the question
is who knows
um there's a lot of different parts to
3d you know there's uh
there's animation as you just saw me
doing
that's the most rudimentary basic
animation you ever seen but it is
animation no doubt there's 3d modeling
there's texturing
there is rigging
there's weight painting
there is sculpting
there's simulations
there's lighting
that's a good one there's lighting uh
there's a lot
there's character design
yeah
there's a lot there's a lot
to dive into
so you can master any one of those
things
you know
and you still wouldn't have mastered 3d
because
there's so many different categories in
3d you know
so it's a tough question it's an
impossible question to answer
i think the question is more
um how long would it take to start
getting results that you actually like
i think that just depends on what you're
trying to create at the end of the day
as well
um
so
yeah and like where you're at like you
know are you starting as a day one what
are you trying to do
yeah that'd be that that's a that's a
specific to that person kind of answer
you know i don't think i can answer that
question
so maybe i'd ask yourself what part of
3d you want to master what do you want
to get good at
okay
let's animate this thing right so i made
this mock like
kind of hud layout
we're gonna bring it to its final design
and then we're gonna animate it based
off of uh what we just animated in c4d
only
js
shout outs to you
very very good stuff
much appreciated just started rendering
hopefully i'll submit it on time i hope
too
fingers crossed dude
best of luck to you
you're rendering right now you got about
a day
plus
to uh you got like a day and a half
to submit man so
i think you'll make it yeah i think
you'll make it
fingers crossed for you
visual do you have any of your first
renders
um
my first still renders
i do i do have some of my first still
renders you're talking about the first
time i ever started 3d
i do
let me show you
what i started how i started out
um
pictures artwork
cinema 4d
uh yeah okay this is it
this is it right here
one of the first things
i wouldn't say the first thing
but this is one of the first things
that i started
this was another one
um
this is when i got a little bit more
into modeling
you know i
i'm impressed with this actually i am
impressed with this i gotta say
this was like maybe a year or two in
i i put this together
uh this is in c4d r10
um but you know i was doing stuff like
this too
just testing things trying to make it
look nice
messing with my lighting
and not really trying to make anything
for real just more abstract i did this
pendulum i was a huge pendulum fan
so i made this like
pendulum background
which the lighting and stuff was done in
after effects
like i traced it out with a spline
and there's like different different
ones here here's another one
very simple very very very simple this
is a texture i actually made
way back in the day
and i was super proud of it you know
making my own texture in photoshop
and the eggs i of course i pho did a
photoshop overlay right i did this like
grungy photoshop overlay because i was
all about that at the time
yeah dude there was five tutorials back
then no joke dude
no joke
codex you watched
schlott's
walkthrough i don't know who shallot is
that is a name
a vghs and you never knew i was shotbot
yes i was shotbot
seasons one through three
good times very very good times
oh man shopbot days
uni bikes i made these uni bikes i
thought this was like the sickest thing
ever
i was like oh man just like super cool
motorcycle thing
um
obviously it's just primitives you know
there's some primitives i think i have a
bullying going here
wow that's
advanced that is advanced
um and then eventually i got to like
this i was very proud of this when i did
this
and this was for the fallout 3 short
film i did on my youtube channel i mean
on this channel right i got a bunch of
short films
way way back
um and then i did stuff like this i was
really proud of how this turned out and
i think it was just um
images from nasa plugged into like
different
this may have been 3ds max because i
switched to 3ds max for 6 years
um
this one was for a contest i won this
contest it was for an airsoft company it
was called red wolf airsoft and um i
made it like a little intro for them
and you can even see my look at my shade
here the
i don't even technically know
what this is called my seams are not
it's not my seams it's just bad uh bad
materials basically it's stretched out
yeah my uvs it's not unwrapped properly
so you can see like it's all janky
but this background this this texture i
made this texture too i was really proud
i was like making textures back in the
day i made a lot of textures back in the
day
so i was really proud of that and i was
like
the same for this wolf right here yeah
this is a texture i made as well
um
[Music]
so it was fun it was really fun to make
my own stuff
and then the most recent thing would be
this this was probably a couple years
ago
and that's just a photo scan i probably
put this together in like an hour
it's a photo
scan and um
yeah very very simple just duplicated
so you know like it is a journey
it is certainly a journey 3d is a
journey um
and you know we do it because we like it
and we stick with it it's fun
and it brings us joy
so
now we are back at it
animating something for
for this scene here
we've come a long way
we've come a very long way
as we started
all right
visual i appreciate you taking me back
there that was a good
good little trip
remember you laying there
and there's more stuff too there's more
crap like
different scenes you know
starting getting into environments
there's a program called view
like this one here
this is all i had back in the day this
was this was it this was the best i had
this was cool too i made this thing i
was like oh that's kind of cool and then
this tree i was a huge fan of how this
tree turned out this took like
eons to it took so long to render i
remember
oh
but now we got it easy with unreal
engine
we got it i think this straight up took
like
24 hours to render or something stupid
oh my god i remember one time i tried to
render something out of view
and spelled v-u-e
and
it took
four days to render one frame
and no joke when it came down the last
couple hours
i was living in atlanta at the time
uh there was a thunderstorm going and it
cut the power right at the last like two
hours of this four hour four day
it was a four day still render
so stupid
um mr clay what's up dude how many hours
am i in to this piece
oh man
a lot a lot a lot a lot
i average probably an hour and a half
every day
on the weekdays
let's find out
um
1.5
times five
so let's just call it eight hours a week
for four weeks now
all right plus
let's see
thank you soto he's telling he's giving
me math
out here in my in my in my ears
i was trying to do i was trying to do it
i was trying to do it
what did i say eight eight times four
yeah 32. um
plus what else
these streams
so that's like
three hours
plus another 12
right
um
i don't know i feel like is that it 44
hours that's it
feels like i've been working on this
thing
yeah maybe maybe like 50 hours around 50
hours or so uh michael james hey thanks
for the super chat is anyone from
corridor doing this challenge i don't
know
i have no idea i don't think so
i know my buddy jan was trying to do
this challenge
and he was at corridor for a time
so maybe does that count i don't know
okay
let's design this thing let's do this
all right uh let's show you all a little
after effects work
ah because after effects i've used after
effects
more than i've used
any
3d software
so stand back
and uh get ready to watch master work
no i'm 100 joking
i'm no master in after effects
i've only watched every andrew kramer
tutorial ever
um but i am no master
all right we got our hud
element let's see let's see let's see
it's a dashboard
how is that possible
there we go
all right we can close that and close
that okay so i just want to recreate
this right
so
i think what i will do here
let's make a new composition this little
button on the bottom left
let's call this um
what technically is this thing
odometer
of some sort and i'll just call it a
thousand by a thousand
24 fps is fine
control y makes it a little background
black is good for now
and let's grab our ellipse tool
and if you double click it bam it's
gonna make a perfect circle
but let's go ahead and control y
make a white solid double click that
ellipse tool bam
exactly what we want mm for mask options
holding control
will um
essentially give you a little bit more
control
over that it'll make it a little slower
you know why not just max it out why not
max it out i'm gonna ctrl d duplicate
that mask subtract it
mm for mask all the mask options hold
ctrl and bring it in
so you see what we're doing
you see what we're doing here
so now we need to get some like lines
and stuff around this uh
around this thing so
what's the best way to do this there's
there's many ways to do this as
you know as there are in 3d as well
they're the same for 2d many ways to do
it uh oh we also need to cut it off at
the bottom too so let's go ahead and
just uh
let's grab the pen tool
from the corner down here
i'll just generally go to the midpoint
and back to the corner
right and we want that to just be i'm
hitting m again right so let's hit make
it subtract
and
holding shift down arrow
something like that i think will do the
trick for us
maybe a little
wider so ctrl t on that bad boy holding
shift
and control
scale it
symmetrically
yeah that feels pretty good to me
wait
all right
now to get all these lines and
dashes and stuff
you know i one i'm wondering if we can
just have it be
nah i'm just gonna do this the
i'm gonna do it this way okay um
as long as we can do this from the
midpoint
we're gonna be
okay so i'm gonna hit uh
control y make another white solid
and we are going to on the rectangle
tool
simply
just draw a little rectangle up here
and i want to make sure that's lined up
with the center point okay so
ctrl r will bring out your ruler let me
get it right there on the center point
and just ensure that this is in here
uh instead of moving the layer i
definitely don't want to move the layer
i want to move the mask
so select the mask down here
arrow keys
holding shift takes you a little faster
all right that's great
control r gets rid of that v for the
pointer tool or selection tool
get it out of there alright so now
since it's right there in the center
point i can
uh i can essentially rotate this thing
around
and duplicate it as needed right
so
how many of these little points do i
want
one two three four five six
okay
all right so it looks like we're going
straight up 90 degrees
bam
i'ma duplicate it again ctrl d
negative 90.
connell's asking uh is it okay to add a
bit of lens to distortion in the post
for the final submission of the
challenge yeah i'd say it's okay it has
a little bit of lens distortion
it's fine
don't see why not
good times i'm trying to figure out what
you're saying here use the index
expression to easily duplicate
index
times 60-60 on the first layer
well on position
on rotation
index
times 60-60
i don't understand
if i set this up properly if i duplicate
it again
oh my god
dude
what
what on earth good times hd
you crazy man what
always learning something new
that's insane
okay
so instead of 60
let's try
what does 80 look like
that probably won't be
symmetrical would it
index
all right
oh
good thing we got that limiter on there
um
that's quite the technique i like that a
lot wow
i think 15 is the way to go and then
i'll
break them up from there
and i'm going to delete these guys
ctrl shift c pre-compose move everything
just computation
yes
g for that mass tool
m for your mask options subtract him out
of there
and then we'll also
bring our triangle down
wrong layer
so if you don't know how many times you
did that hit p and right click and reset
it
make sure you bring the mask not the
layer
ctrl shift h gets rid of your masks
and your huds and stuff
okay
now i also want to get rid
let's see if i want to get rid of every
other one
this is definitely a janky
work around here
subtract those guys
that feels pretty good
dez
much appreciated for that super chat
wondering if we need another mod
currently
we have no plans to add any moderators
at the moment
but i'm sure that won't be the case
forever so
um
we'll probably let the community know if
we need to do something like that so
definitely uh
you know
stay
with what as they say
stay tuned
just increase the angle and duplicate
again i see
um
all right let's bust
out
um
some smaller ones
to go in between
all right so let's do
[Music]
get up in that mask ctrl shift h if you
can't find your mask you're turning your
mask on and off right here this little
button just below
this uh this viewing window here i'm
gonna take this and
something like that
and uh maybe just
yeah that's that's cool that's cool
that's cool
all right let's do this again
so we go
index
oh 15
5
every 2.5
let's try that
yeah i mean that totally works
i have to go to town on this thing huh
good thing we only have to make one
awesome
let's grab all those
ctrl shift c pre-compose
g for the mask tool for the pen tool
rather
m
for your mask options and get them out
of there
sweet
that's great
that is great
um
you know other than that
i might do one more just for the detail
let's copy that top one again
and we will make this thing
half the size
and we'll do it every uh
15 i think
is the sweet spot r we're gonna alt
click the rotation stopwatch
it works
and yeah we technically have double in
the amount that we need but
i think that's okay
and i'm also going to
crunch this down
just a little bit
or maybe not because i don't want to
select all that stuff again
it's going to be fine
ctrl shift c
pre-comp all of it
g
to mask it out
m
for your mask options and we'll subtract
it ctrl shift h gets rid of
the mask itself michael james shoutouts
can't wait to get toasted and watch the
top 100
hey man you do what you got to do have a
good one
that's awesome
i can't wait to watch that top 100
myself
it's going to be a good one
all right
that's our odometer
now
but depending on like what
uh it's trying to read
we're gonna have different um
different numbers on this thing
so let me actually just
get this one up real quick
gosh
i need a new keyboard
my control key is so crusty
did it straight up do it again
goodness
okay i'm done
screw it my control key
uh
all right um so this is our odometer
but we're also gonna add
hmm
let's go ahead and add the actual uh
the little dial as well so i'll make a
new solid
double click that elliptical mask tool
to get it right in the center
sweet
and from here let's go
the rulers
so there'll be a few different styles
of these so i'm just setting this up so
that we can have it be pretty darn
symmetrical
and let's go ahead and
make some
points here
and i'll snap these on later
and by later i mean
right
now
i wish there was an easier way to clear
the rulers
sweet
looking good
good time says using shape layers will
make your life easier as you can use all
the associated options you can use the
radial wipe on a circle to make that
shape
good to know
good to know
okay so that will be our
our dial
okay
let's see here
all right so i want to essentially
duplicate this
well we need the numbers too
and the numbers will change based off of
what the dial is so
probably shrink the dial down just a
touch
let's grab the text tool
let's figure out the font we like
what
uh how did this work before
there we go okay
that's not bad
that's not bad
bank gothic
i like that
let's do it
let's set it up so it's uh
centered up uh center text
flush left flush middle i don't know
and i wonder
if we can do that same rotation trick
here i bet we can
so let's take that anchor point
or if we hit y we can move the anchor
point
to the middle
but we're gonna have to be cool with the
scale i think unless
the font size can be changed yes
wonderful
and then let's go rotation
and set uh
index
times
i think we did 30.
oh
shoot
now that makes sense unless
unless
that can be changed with
a setting
hmm
does anyone know
oh shoot
i mean it's not that big of a deal to
hand place it
there's no way like for it to stay
upright
screw it
i am doing it the old fashioned way
jacker you ain't wrong
you are not wrong my friend
all right
and then one thing i know i'm going to
need is a uh
it's a good digital font so i'm going to
go to
dafont.com here
and
there should be a
lcd
yep
i'll try and find one that's not
italicized yeah that works
oh this is a good one
digital display
let's do it
i'm pretty sure i should already just be
in there
because i'd love like a
readout in the center of this thing too
yep
just like that
sweet alright
so from here i think i'll just duplicate
this and start
changing some numbers a little bit here
um
okay
so we have speed here
i think these are already typed out
so that's going to be heat that's water
i don't know what that is
i don't know what that is
definitely there'll be one for fuel
but honestly like it doesn't need to be
too specific because
you know
not really gonna see it
you'll see it but you're not gonna see
the details rather
all right
do
what else we got fuel
fuel and gas that's obviously the same
thing we have water fuel
temperature and what else
besides speed
yeah rpm is good
all right
air conditioning level
that'll be rpm
and we will do
so these other ones won't be moving too
much
let's do rpm closer to the camera
temperature and water we can scale those
down
sweet
all right then i'm gonna make this last
little piece here
cool something like that
hmm
and then i want to chop
let's see
how do i want to do this
uh let's duplicate that and because i
want to fill this up like a bar right
it's gonna this will be the shifter
so uh so the driver knows when to shift
and
i'll duplicate the mask
set it to
subtract
and walk it in
there's an outline
i'll make a new
white solid
copy that mask on there that's going to
be what's actually going to fill this
thing up
and we'll fill this up
we can do this a few different ways we
can animate it on
with like a radial wipe or something
or just a simple mask it might be easier
yeah something like that
or rather i'll take that mask
paste it on to the original
and set it to
uh
intersect
hmm
or is it now this is intersect i think
there we go
yeah that right the first time
sweet so that'll animate on
awesome and then let's see let's go back
to that reference
okay so that's the
the gear you're in
and this is your miles per hour
um
that's an m okay
sweet all right that's i mean that's
pretty good
awesome so we just need to animate that
but before we animate it let's uh
let's talk about the community works and
progresses which are pretty much like
almost final at this point i'd say
and then i'll animate this thing
and then make a material out of it
making a missive material i think it'll
be pretty sweet
all right let's see here let's go whip
first stream
see where we're at seramonte probably
has a message of some sort
telling me where it starts
[Music]
i don't know do you soto
do you have a message where whip for
stream starts
oh favorite 26 boom right here
okay
take a look y'all
fwed women's
you're almost done
nice
very nice i love your background i love
your lighting
you said any suggestions
i'd say just maybe a little something in
the foreground here don't really know
what this is if it's a bed or what but
i love it
little inkling
infinite journeys up on here yes i dig
it
reason two we got a little uh
a little spirited away here
huge fan
very very huge fan i love it good stuff
man awesome
edis with the flying machine
mustache in the wind
oh this is awesome
i love it very very creative
well animated it's funny
i assume this is you
ah this is great
i wonder what's in the bag though
is that the weights for landing when
you're trying to land it
probably who knows
whoa
that's crazy okay um i feel like we're
missing the character in the foreground
when we're transitioning to a thing here
um
but i do
really like the black and white scroll
here
too much information
i love
that idea very much
but i just feel like we're missing the
character
in the foreground i guess that's your
hand but
i don't know it's pushing it it's
pushing it
i dig it though i dig it
alo
nice little sci-fi scene oh this is cool
i like your i like your colors a lot
actually
nice background lighting
i could play a game like this that's for
sure
cristo
work in progress pass here
nice
uh i need to sharpen up that character
animation a lot and put into proper
wooden boxes and post apocalyptic
buildings but we'll be done on time that
is good to hear chris though very good
to hear
we got some pictures uh void ad what is
this
oh this is cool
dig your lighting
very sci-fi
very dark
i love that background i love it it's a
drop ship super cool
heck yeah that's great
blender man we got a submission from
blenderman here keeping it old school
that's awesome we saw this one last week
i like it you're pushing it to the max
there
going with a different style
oh very very sad
situation oh goodness
goodness it's so dark
wow that's intense
very sad
very sad who's that in the foreground
someone creeping up in the foreground is
that that grudge girl
interesting
world war ii soldiers
very safe on this train feels very safe
on that train
uh extreme derpy
that's very fun
wow
so there's a tornado scene going on
outside
this dude took advantage of that
opportunity
wow that's really intense that's a
really really intense background there
wow i wonder what this kid did
what could this what it could have this
this punk little kid right here what
could he have done
i'm assuming this is you you probably
photo scanned yourself
not to say you're punk kid i'm just
saying in this world of tornadoes and
like jail cell carriages i wonder what
could have happened
whoa
in very interesting
why is this is this person driving
on the right
huh
are they piloting that drone thing who
knows
that's very interesting though
john
cool looking scene i'm excited to see it
in motion
zeus what do you got
wow okay hold on
is that my computer lagging or is that
the animation
this is crazy
geez okay what's going on here um
there's a knife in the pillow
is this the guy here
did he murder his wife what is happening
oh so many questions
so many questions
i love your design though man your
design is solid wow there's a ring on
the bed
go
was his wife murdered and he's drinking
himself
into a frenzy what
wow
that's nuts
good stuff zeus
mr john
we got a world war ii
ish scene
sweet
nice cozy train
let's see let's see let's see there's a
lot of renders can't get to a mall
oh that's cool
that's cool that's cool
wow i dig that
i just want
i would just watch out for uh
i would watch out for
your motion blur it looks like
potentially
and that window
frame is kind of lost
that would be my only note
i like your i like the feeling of i like
the motion the motion is solid i'm just
missing that window frame feeling
i know most people are doing a literal
window frame
others are doing uh
you know they're kind of blocking the
edges of frame
in a creative way
love me some stop motion
some claymation
ah it's always so much fun to see in 3d
that's awesome rage squid cool stuff
cool stuff
luca what you got
all right little dance party here okay
okay
this just reminds me of the
galaxy's edge
there's a ride in disneyland
where you like go through the whole
the whole base and everything and
there's uh
man i don't know star wars stuff there's
a bunch of walkers and stuff and you're
like
going through trying to escape the uh
dare i say bad guys i'mma say it the bad
guys thing that's that's all i'm doing
with that
oh this is cool
i like it
very creative very unique
mr upside down
very good stuff
joshua whitney
we remember this from uh
from last week a very sad scene here
but i'm glad to see you finishing this
thing
oh wow interesting
very crisp that is a darn crisp render
wow
we got infinite journeys here we got
papers some rules
sacred or ordeal and conquering demons
don't be afraid of infinite journeys
i like it that's awesome
heck yeah nice dynamics here on the
necklace
asdf gasped
if that's how you say your name
let's see let's oh this looks unique
what is this
this ain't nothing
that ain't
an infinite journey submission we're
doing infinite journeys here
whoa
whoa
wow that's crazy
look at the gun barrels they're steaming
wow that's cool
that is cool
israel
fourness
that is cool stuff cool stuff
jamie
yeah wow okay very interesting very
unique
i could see an entire music video like
this
i feel like there's already one
i'm thinking of it i don't know what it
is but i like it
oh take on me yeah
jamie that's cool
okay
all right i'm down for this one
dnl pn i can't even pronounce that name
but this is
very cool
that is sick
yes
yes dude
the render quality is great
the lighting's great
the character and the story is great the
composition is great your visual
storytelling is great
that is awesome
dnl i cannot wait
oh
little frog train here i'm down
yeah
actually i really like that it's a frog
boat actually
dang i won't play a video game like that
that's cool
rhino warrior
yes yes
my only note is i would love to see the
fish in a profile just to know for a
fact it's a fish
that'll be my only note
other than that it's darn perfect that's
awesome
rhino warrior good stuff
all right apologies to anyone
surrenders i'm skipping here
oh we got some elephants what is that
oh wow
a little photography mission
going on a quest
get off your phone son there's elephants
outside
that's awesome yeah good stuff
good stuff
why
francopaska
nice man very interesting design here i
would say maybe a little motion blur on
that cloth could help it out just a
touch
and yeah a little motion blur for the
background i think could help you out
overall
if you're in a pinch real smart motion
blur
in
after effects could work but
it might be a little tough it might be
some some artifact in there i remember
this one this is a cool one
belly i'm excited for that full
render full render
ah it's gonna be sweet
oh so it's like
i get it all right so it's the kid who
has the imagination out the window
but the parent
is reading some books
that might be a little boring intro to
quantum mechanics
definitely not your uh
your your happy fiction book there
nice
nice this is all wood full wood scene
here
that's fun
i like it samuel that's good stuff
oh
doom
polly gloat
yes yes yes yes yes yes that's all i'm
gonna say is yes yes yes
that's awesome
big ol robo here and a sleeping kitty
wow sleeping cat's pretty good
boston dynamics
or boss town dynamics rather on the tv
gotta respect it
what's going on outside
some city stuff uh
people running
pretty sweet
pretty sweet
oh m design
yeah oh yes
yes yes yes
this is amazing this is amazing
a little tricky on the window silhouette
though
i think that's the only thing i'm not
sure how
when i see what yeah it's it's it's like
you're framed up here you're framed up
here you know you got your
your situation going on over there
you are blocking the frame on that side
but it does open up there it's tough
that's when it gets tricky you know
otherwise this render
is fantastic
fantastic
look at the mushroom
smoke coming out of these things
what the mushrooms do though that's what
i'm curious about
does it allow them to fly
because
no these are blimps these are definitely
blimps up there but you have these
floating particles up in the air and i'm
wondering if that's like mushroom
cap stuff i don't know but man this is
so cool
what a great scene
god dang
oh wow this looks awesome
very well done
can't wait to see that in motion
sano it's going to be sweet
obliviart what you got son
sweet man you got some incense going off
fortune teller okay so she's a fortune
teller
very cool
i love the feeling of this scene it's
like
reminds me of kiki's delivery service
when they go to get the
was it the apple pie
oh there's a little mouse up here
chilling i love it
so beautiful
i will say my only note is to
potentially just bring your gamma down
a little bit
it feels a little like washed out and
bright i wonder if you were to increase
the contrast the touch make it a touch
darker
so you can see a bit more of your
highlights i wonder what it would feel
like then
just the test
cgmo
this is a cool one i like your design
style
traveling from some planet back to earth
yes
i love it
i'm a big fan of this one
i like the way it feels like the
lighting
character's cool it's more of a cartoony
kind of vibe very good stuff
oh what's this
yeah
i'm hoping for some more samples
we can only hope
because this is amazing
yes yes yes yes
so good
oh my goodness
this is absurd
oh there's so it's so intense
wow that's nuts chase
that is insane
nuts wow
i can't wait for this montage these
montages are going to be so cool y'all
oh this is beautiful i love your
background
yes
painted background yes yes
ah it's so good painted textures too
wow
that's so beautiful
japan pepin
oh you have a bowling ball character
it's bowling ball town
you gotta talk to connor
ball street oh the ball street journal i
see
um forced through 2 000 machines oh i
get it it's the ball
from dynamic machines
that's so good
and i'm calling it too i love it
lady new york ah there's so much going
on
you have the custom ads too
[Music]
lost your marbles contact dr b round
default sphere was here i love it
ah it's so good it's so good bollywood
in the back
marble
that's awesome
jeff and pepin i dig it that's
so much fun
pizza knot what do you got
brutal
yo is this kid's arm
chromed out for some reason
it looks chromed out
are you is it supposed to be chromed out
oh
you're seeing through the skin and you
can see the bones
interesting
i don't know if that's on purpose or not
but that'd be my only note
is to probably fix that skin up a little
bit
but that's a crazy scene you got there
[Music]
quite a storm going outside but luckily
you got your pizza planet
pizza is always good
especially
when it's real real scary outside
oh sweet
dollar deer
yeah
look at the driver
[Laughter]
the driver with this hat what the heck
[Laughter]
oh man that's great
that is great
i love it i love it i love it i love it
jameel
what have you changed it looks like you
changed
do i remember
did you change the floor a little bit
did you change the
inside of this thing maybe a touch
what's that yellow
thing oh it's a helicopter i see i see
nice
good stuff
oh bouncy hippo
wow that's cool
definitely reminds me of bioshock wow oh
wow okay so
that's such a cool way to do it okay
so you're showing the vehicle that this
woman is riding
i'm assuming she's on one of these
things too
being carried by a whale that's such a
creative way to do it
to duplicate the vehicle and put it on
the outside
and she's painting it too
man that's cool bouncy hippo i love it
oh mitch mitch okay i've been waiting
for this done with rendering your frames
baking some additional smoke and
destruction sims until this morning
here are the raw frames quickly stitched
together
haven't started compositing nor color
grading so excuse the 8-bit blown out
lights
still doing
still lots to do until submission
oh man
yes yes your smoke
yeah you're smoking your sky
and some atmosphere or some fog
dude that's gonna take it over the top
on this thing
this is so good mitch mitch
yes
yes you have been crushing
the weekly challenges and it is
really paying off right here
oh
ah
i can't wait
god it's gonna be so good dez okay so
here's your still
wow it's quite a crazy world where
we're in here okay and then your
animation
oh what is it teleport teleport
situation
interesting
whoa okay what is going on here so
there's like a
woman is dying and
teleports to some crazy world
escaping reality is that what's going on
like
i'm very curious why there's a helmet
here and a toy
interesting
let's see
okay so
the dude is in front of actually the
same person you see dying in the
beginning of the shot
or the dude in front is actually the
same person you see dying in the
beginning of the shot
as he's viewing himself from outside his
body as his soul ascends to heaven the
moment he dies but at the same moment
you can see a film crew has snuck itself
in the reflection of the helmet
so actually this is all just a movie
being shot okay
wow
crazy
crazy
you know it's easier to tell here
i'd probably be able to tell that that's
the dude in the suit
from this angle i'm just curious why the
hell oh the helmet's there to show the
crew that's why you have the helmet
there
um i see
i see
very very interesting des
i look forward to seeing the whole thing
in motion
and raptor what you got
sweet chilling super hard
in egypt
what are these pop popping stuff there's
some black frames popping around up
there
sweet man very cool scene here
i wish i could be here right now i wish
i could be streaming from that spot
right now
oh cg freak
what
is this
yes
yes
so cool
so cool
yeah man i love this cartoony stuff
so fresh so colorful
great way to combine 2d and 3d
ah man that's awesome
so awesome
brutal brutal
straight up captured
emperor divalen
it's a brutal one
milo what is this
ah sleeping on autopilot little blade
runner scene this looks like a mix
between like
vin diesel and like uh
i don't know the first my first reaction
was someone else who i i can't put my
finger on it
but that's cool
i dig it
right what else we got
oh papaxo
yes
yes everyone sit back and enjoy
ah so crazy
god dang so good
so good wow okay amazing beautiful
sketch
got the ink going
some color doing it black and white yep
oh wow the eyeballs came out of his head
look at this look at this look at this
guy's eyeballs they go whoa
unreal engine background
oh
and then you traced over it
shoot
that's very smart
unreal mountains
rotoscoped mountains
wait i don't understand how you went
from
the unreal mountains
to the rotoscope mountains did you just
use them as a reference
i take it
wow dude
jeez
oh
so brutal the teeth that come oh that's
so gross
wow papaxo hats off to you that's so
cool
man good stuff
jones lab
wow this jeez this is nuts
really good stuff
wow
oh this is stressful man
this is darn stressful
being kicked out of your kingdom here
everyone hates you
but you still got enough to eat
and and roll out
in style at least
and someone else is coming in power
wow there's a lot going on here man
and it's very beautiful too that's so
good
jones lab that's a that's incredible the
great murloc what you got
oh that's cool that's very cool
good render quality good lighting
wow
good stuff
great murloc good stuff
no animations yet
all right i dig it though this is cool
this is cool same sum i look forward to
that
character design is killing yet hey man
character design is killing me too
really is
but my goodness this looks incredible
like what is your background here this
looks like footage
geez
all right last three
got a big old window some miximo
characters
blade runner style background here
very nice
sky which you
oh this is awesome
yeah i'm a fan of this one for sure
i think you can lose i'm just me
personally i'm just saying
i think you can use lose all this
smudging on the camera because it's not
going to be in focus it would be out of
focus the smudging on that camera would
definitely be out of focus so i would
i don't think you need it
you don't need it it looks like
it's untracked
surface imperfections on this window
yeah this render is great enough without
it you don't need to you don't need to
like dirtied up with filters and
i i'm sure you have a couple filters on
here i love your grain
that you have and the dust in the
like the particles in the sky here or in
the in this train are nicely done but
you definitely don't need the smudging
on this on the camera
wow what a background too
very good stuff
skye that's awesome
and slash render what do we got
haha
okay
little autopilot situation gone wrong it
got as bad as it can get probably
hey good stuff on the uh
on the windshield wipers here with the
water that looks really nice
[Music]
and that's it y'all
and that's it
shoot some good stuff some really really
good stuff
ah i'm excited i'm very excited to see
it all
the deadline is tomorrow tomorrow night
pacific standard time 11 59 pm pst
i'm gonna animate this here and call it
so probably take an hour or so to
animate this up
and then we gonna bounce
it's not gonna i gotta eat
and then i gotta keep working to be
honest with you all i gotta keep working
okay
how long we've been going for
three hours
been three hours already
[Music]
dang it's been three hours
all right
so um
for our water
let's label these do we even need to
label them
let's try
let's at least try
unless
it's all capped nope okay yep
it'll kind of be like alien looking
or kind of another language
i'm down for that
so we got our rpms here
[Music]
here's our temperature
and this will just be our our fuel
all right so
let's see here
so that switch right when that switch
goes
358
is when all the stuff kicks off
and essentially boots up
so i'll just start everything
let's do uh okay
so the water here um
what do i want to do i'm just going to
make up some stuff
in fact i'm going to skip
yep
and i'll start going to there and it'll
probably come back down to
ease down to 20.
whatever 20 of what i don't know 20
gallons
who knows doesn't matter
and we'll just easy ease that
and this one as well
i guess all of them
and it's going to be
let's see
so 10.50
minus
350 okay 750 frames
basically goes to there and i think once
even once we start the engine and
everything
[Music]
and we take off
over time it'll probably just drop a
little bit just to give it a little bit
of motion
technically this would be a very bad
thing
if this were to happen
you're losing water real quick
but just for the sake of uh
of the animation but you're not even
gonna see it that's so slow you're not
gonna see it
with that first one boom and then from
643
just take off essentially
or maybe here
technically it's a land speed record
and it's a very small detail furthest
away from camera so we are good on that
angle
next up we got the fuel
so let's see how we want to do this
it's usually empty to full
you can probably take this and
call it one half
and we could probably work some other
fractions in here
about three quarters
one quarter
and same deal here for the odometer on
the water i'm just gonna like they're
all gonna have the same kind of boot up
animation
and we stay on full
and i'll just stay on full
and this number oh the water number
technically
uh there is no number there okay that's
fine
i don't think we really need anything
there unless
maybe just a simple uh
a simple bar being filled up
i'll duplicate that
subtract it mm for mask options hold
ctrl
just get a little outline there
and then
i'll duplicate it again
that full thing and then essentially
what we will do is we'll
mask it
set it to
intersect
and animate
this mask on
from ignition
what that looks like
why the digital readout would take
longer to fill up than the actual analog
one but then again it's all analog or
it's all digital because
it's on a lcd screen
whatever
uh nivlock gaming
what is up
thank you for the super chat keep up the
great work much love from a canadian fan
i appreciate it thank you
love me from canada i was in whistler
over christmas
that was
amazing it was like santa claus
santa town over there
so good i've also been a montreal blonde
as well for some for some snowboarding
too
and that's also like santa town
it's a good time in canada been to
calgary been to toronto
but thank you
my friend i appreciate you very much
all right what else
we got boot up animation
sweet all right um let's get this
central readout
booted up as well
so the miles per hour will start out at
zero
the gear
um
i mean technically
technically it'd start off in neutral uh
that's what i would do
um
cool and then this this bar here
will also start at zero
so i can probably start with it up here
and just have it come across
i'll probably get that uh fuel to start
a little faster too
rpms is next and when you start the
engine we'll probably
have it be somewhere uh let's see
okay
what is it rpms is usually times a
thousand right
arden you're saying you have you lost
all motivation for your render
and authoring all things cg even though
you love it
what do you do i'd say take a break man
take a break
if you're pushing it 24 7
you're gonna burn out
take a break
depending on you know there could be a
million other answers to it but i'd say
take a break and um get outside go for a
walk go for hikes
work out perhaps
just get away from your computer get
away from your phone get away from
screens
take a break
that's helped me in the past
take two weeks off of 3d don't touch 3d
at all
and then you'll start to get um
you know
it'll come back it'll come back in time
[Music]
mmm i see i see we got different uh
setups here you can switch it back
i should just trust sotoma sotomante's
got it handled y'all
i'm
i'm moving things all over
he's got it set up nice and easy
right let's see
for these numbers here okay so for the
boot up
sequence
we definitely want that here for the
for the needle and then it's going to
quickly drop to
whatever the car idle is at which is
maybe 1500
it's going to hold at 1 500 until
takeoff so
takeoff is
oh no no take off
technically as this lever gets cranked
so starting at
450
to 528
so 450
to
528 we're gonna
we're gonna rev up
warm up the engine a little bit
y'all we got over 1 000
submissions just want to say we got over
a thousand submissions
um
so
keep them coming
keep them coming y'all
we got day and a half left
let's break some records see if we can
break 2400
let's do it
all right
let's ease that out
yes indeed
and we can actually probably have it
happen over
double the time
and then we're gonna shift into
first gear
and that's going to
boom
635
so right at 6 35
we're gonna go from n
to
first gear
and the miles per hour will
increase in time
uh from here so let's see if we can't
do a little counter here we'll go from
zero zero zero
i'm pretty sure there's a way to do this
uh text
source text maybe
uh more options there's like uh animate
we wanna animate the
character value or offset
one of these two let's try offset
all right that doesn't do what we want
uh let's try value
oh
i just wanted to count up
um
range
no
source text to a slider
okay
so we'll do
what is it
slider control
on here source text
there we go all right
pick whip source text and go up into the
slider control
that works i wanted to say zero zero
zero though but
um
probably okay
all right so shacker i'm following you
here you said basically hook up to a
slider
get
then to get rid of the fractions add the
expression there are no fractions though
i just want it to have three integers at
all times
i also want it to be flush
left
there we go
that works dude like that works
it's all good
i think i would just fake it i would
have uh
have another one out here
and just delete them as it goes up
all right so from here let's take that
slider control
go to the end and i think we're gonna
try and hit like
some crazy speed like uh
i don't know
eight
862.
oh i see what you're saying
i'm getting i need whole numbers okay so
that's where your your math.round slider
expression comes in shakur what do you
think on that is that in the source text
or
huh
let me just try and add that
i don't know
add math.round to
what hmm
source text i did i did though
oh unless you're saying
unless you're saying like this
hmm
uh
so
capital m that's what's gonna do it
no
hold on wait
what what the heck did i just do
what
the capital m
all right
hey i appreciate it you got me through
you know
all right let's see what our shifting
times are so we
much appreciate it help thanks for
helping me get through that yeah
all right so from that moment so from
frame
6 30
to 7 50.
630 to 750 all right
so 6 30
to
750
we're going to second gear
so we'll do
uh
the sky animates
up
and then when we shift we go back
oh i chopped the wrong thing i just
realized
there we go that works
all right the next time we shift
it's looking like
8.99
so after the shift is when it goes down
so
it's 9 10 technically
yeah and then this one is
7 45 it's after the shift is when it
goes down
762
more like it
and then
starts building up at 6 39.
yeah that's good that's good
sweet
now i'll just throw that in there
and change the gears
so that's one
and we shift to two
and we shift to
three
and we shift to 4 but this will probably
be
off camera
sweet
great
and let's adjust the rpms
to match what we just did
all right so it looks like we'll start
it
they'll drop here
we will crank up to
this point and
drop them
to like uh
maybe here or something
and then we're going to crank them up
again
and one more time
sweet
i probably don't need these numbers
awesome all right and the temperature
let's get that going
i have no idea what the temperature of a
engine
gets to
but i'mma just make some stuff up
do
[Music]
all right if you're beyond 450 then
you're probably having a rough day so
let's uh
let's go ahead and
bring these down
scale them down rather
do
and let's have this number
climb actually
so from
the engine booting up
it's just gonna be at like whatever
temperature
oh yeah from frame zero let's go ahead
and grab this
odometer boot
bam
that on the dial okay
and then we're gonna come down to
probably
i don't know how hot is it outside
102.
so we'll come down to
100
and then as the engine warms up
we'll increase the temperature
and that's going to happen with rpms
so we'll probably we'll start
here
450
and we'll just warm it up
basically the entire time
start at 450
and it'll just get warmer and warmer
probably something in here
nice and slow there okay and then we'll
just take this number to match
for the 123.
all right temperature will start at
let's get this on the slider again
so
let's do shifts control what am i doing
slider control
source text
um
math
dot round
to the slider
it's a hot day all right and then we
will
animate this up
so what 125
138
oh shacker that's a crazy idea
hook up the number to the rotation value
and do some simple math that's awesome
i think it's fine as is though
all right let's see what it looks like
so that's when you boot up the car
and we should have
rpms
go in yep
and we go first gear
second gear
third gear
that's great
that is great
so
it is
it's gonna be that time let's let's just
see let's test it out real quick i want
to see if this actually works um
png sequence
let's do it
come on after effects don't crash on me
now
there we go
png sequence
all right let me see if i get this
working for y'all
check this out though so i have these
fog cards that i was telling you about
so
that's with the fog cards in the
background and this is without the fog
cards in the background
it looks horrible
and that looks much much better
and i don't have to do any volumetric
stuff it's just
nice and easy
okay so let's see if i can't get that to
be an emissive here on this screen
let me set it up for you and then once
we get it working i'll show you the
result
so the first thing we need to do is just
make an octane diffuse material
and we should be able to just bust out
this png sequence which is almost done
rendering
bam all right
all right the diffuse channel let's go
find this
select that first image
and to make it a sequence let's see it's
been a minute
to common
and
let's see what
animate preview yeah
wow it's been so long
what is it click on this
oh here we go here we go
that's a linear um
i don't think i have to do anything on
this screen but animation
calculate it yep
and then we animate the preview yeah
that's what it is sweet okay so that's
set up
now we just need to have it displayed
here on this screen
and we need to make sure it matches up
all right i can't see jack diddly here
so
really it's not the diffuse but it's
more so the emission
um
so
let's go a blackbody emission
and the texture i'll plug this in here
to the texture
and that's way too intense we'll do
surface brightness
and just do it as one
and you can see we kind of have
something here let me let me switch
my
oh it's upside down that's why it's
upside down
do
and it's a bit warped so let me just
keep working it here on my end
but it's doing what it's supposed to be
doing and uh emission wise now let's
i believe we have to
here i'll make this easy for y'all
and it is indeed animating so that's
great
now it's upside down so let's fix that
um
hmm
let's maybe try uh
because i can't put a transform on this
so it needs to be an image texture
let's pull this
and hopefully it's still animated
it is not
so
let's
try plugging it into diffuse
clicking on
this and oh yep i can set it up over
here
calculate bam alright so now it's
animated as an image texture
great that's what we want
i can set this to float it's black and
white
i can also
pop this into the opacity
and i wonder do i invert it
i do all right that way there we go
all right so now projection
and transform
for projection let's go box
transform let's take the scale down to
point
two all right
or we could do uh let's see
hmm
suv is kind of jacked up
i mean we could just try box for a
second
let's uh let's square off with it
all right and then let's just try and uh
let's try and fix this
okay
then it needs to be scaled up
it's about as large as it gets it now
needs to be flipped upside down so
rotation let's go 180 on it
there it is
and we just need to transform it down
there 1.5
so close
1.65
i wish there was an easier way to do
this 1.6
i think we need to scale it down just a
touch point
three
three
0.09 was at 0.08
0.09 0.091
ah yes 0.09
8.
all right knees we need to move it over
wow
it's real touchy
so i can't go into the texture mode and
transform it via the gizmo because i've
switched the uv projection to box that
will not work this way
but we're very close
this is the annoying way to do it no
doubt
that's just about it um
a little lower 0.101
that's about it point one oh
three
three
all right that's it
so now
it's on there and it's animated
and we can make that as bright as we
want we can change the color on it
well that's awesome i'm happy with that
and i think
with that you know i got a couple more
huds to make
[Music]
be like rocket booster info and that
kind of stuff um but you know what y'all
it's about time for me i'm hungry
i can't wait to finish this render i
still got a lot of work to do
wish me luck please please please wish
me luck on this one
i wish y'all luck
as you are submitting your renders uh
over the next day and a half they are
due tomorrow
night 11 59 pm pst or 23 59 same thing
uh pacific standard time that's the
important thing don't get mixed up
specific
it's a specific pacific standard time
okay
very specific
if it's not if y'all don't miss this all
right
please
don't do all this work for nothing get
it in in time
all right
it's gonna be amazing
but thank you all i'll take questions
for the next like three minutes
i'll chill with you just for a second
kind of wind down here
and then i'm gonna call i'm get some
food
uh wouldn't that be 12 a.m
yeah it's basically midnight it's 11 59
p.m
so the minute monday comes around it's
too late okay
so get it in
now maybe that day
for me right pacific standard time
monday as soon as monday rolls around
it's over
um
for you your days might be a little
different as long as you know
it's 23 59
uh that's military time 24 hour clock
or 11 59
pacific standard time i've said it
enough that i think we're good we're
good i wish you all the best of luck
how am i doing on my feature film thank
you tina for asking it is going i am
writing and it's very difficult
but i finally figured out what the plot
is of this movie i can't wait to tell
you all about it i'm so excited
uh it's gonna be
it's gonna be a hoot all right it's an
action comedy okay
um
it's where my heart that's where my
heart is at action comedy good old
jackie chan stephen chow kind of stuff
um
dominic
looking sweet so far wishing you a
smooth run for the finish line thank you
brother i appreciate you and as well for
you i wish you
that smooth run as well
um
what else y'all just at
punisher me it's a little easier to see
hmm
[Music]
yeah um
escander i don't know if that's how you
pronounce your name but
um you've learned a lot
and it's your first time joining
all the best to everyone that's awesome
i'm really glad you learned a lot it's
the whole point of all this gotta learn
and grow together
um and it's gonna come together here in
this next month with these two montages
i can't wait can't wait it's the best
part
uh is corridor doing a video on this
like the marvel challenge i highly doubt
it i highly doubt it as it is one day
away from submission time
and there's no word so far of any of
that so
lucas no worries my brother
shout outs to you man um the whole
stream will be
live right here uh and available on my
youtube channel forever and ever and
ever
so you have to worry about that
when will i watch the video with you
guys great question all right so next
saturday um
i believe that is march 5th at 10 45 a.m
pacific standard time
i'm going to be watching the
top 100 videos with the two guest judges
all right
i believe it's two right now we got one
locked in i'm looking for another um no
announcements yet as to who they are but
stay tuned and uh you will be
you will be pleased i will say that you
will be pleased
but we're going to watch them we're
going to take a look at all 100 awesome
submissions we're going to say all the
things we love about them we're going to
put them all up on a pedestal and then
i'm going to announce the five winners
of the infinite journeys challenge who
is gonna win
a whole bunch of good stuff we're
talking maxon one subscriptions wacom
tablets looking glass portraits uh
mograph.com courses
we have
uh what else do we have we have rococo
smart gloves in store we have uh for
first place a full rococo motion capture
bundle that's with the gloves with their
new smartsuit pro 2 as well as an
all-expenses paid trip to camp mograph
this year uh in september i'll be there
so that'll be a good time you'll come
out we'll fly you out and um no matter
where you live
in the country we will not in the
country in the world we will fly you out
um as long as uh
well
you know if you're 12 years old
you might need a parent to come with you
i'll say that
i will say that there's a lot of really
good young blender kids out there
um
so yeah we'll figure all that stuff out
later but it's gonna be a good time uh
what else
oh yes and we got another awesome
announcement next week we're doing some
really cool stuff on the discord um
we're at the tail end of making sure
everything is kind of locked in place
but on the discord server it's about to
get
it's got it's about to get pretty sweet
um
with uh
what should i say can i say anything
i'm not gonna say anything yet i'm not
gonna say anything yet i will say
it's gonna be a pretty cool announcement
so don't miss next week's stream please
all 357 of you who are here right now i
better see you
next week all right
because we got some crazy stuff coming
down
coming down the pike all right tried the
chai recipe yesterday lucas so good and
well no i actually didn't say i'm
putting words in your mouth now so much
fun to make i'm glad you liked it yes i
am very glad you liked it love me some
chai very good
stuff will the jury stream be that's
next weekend next weekend y'all
the fifth
um
and if that's about it y'all
i'm up to bounce
because i'm tired and i'm hungry and i
got more work to do after this too
so thank you all
for a very good time for a very good
stream i'll see you next week for the
live judging stream as well as a
announcement big announcement for the
discord server so wish me luck i wish
all y'all luck can't wait to see our
submissions
and i'll catch you later peace out y'all
[Music]
two
[Music]
so
[Music]
you